bonjour nicolas de shanghai merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
d'abord quelle est l'atmosphère à bangui
aujourd'hui et dans tout le pays donc au
lendemain des élections
un calme relatif
il ya ben dis donc par contre on entend
parler de quelques bruits de bottes d'un
certaines villes de décor aux quelles
villes exactement vers le but
on a entendu parler de celui qu est-ce
que si tu sais si proche de bangui et de
l'autre vous avez pris le relais de
l'ancien président françois bozizé à la
tête d'une coalition de l'opposition
code 20-20 vous demandiez d'ailleurs le
report des élections qui ont finalement
eu lieu à la date prévue dans un calme
relatif
que comptez vous faire maintenant donc
il faut dire que c'est pas plus
compliqué qu'il en partie cassé votre
puisque bon nombre d'électeurs et en
province en mouvement les troubles
militaires des affrontements au plan
militaire n'ont pas pu participer à
celui là est pour les
l'endroit où nous votre appui avoir lieu
nous attendons de voir les résultats que
les gens qui doivent être proclamés par
là de quelques national aux élections au
plus tard le 4 janvier
on parlait de françois bozizé justement
il il diriger votre la coalition cod 20
20 c'est toujours le cas oui la toile
les positions la présidence est
tournante
donc nous avions eu il ya qui en était
le président ensuite il ya eu une année
qui avait assuré l'intérim pendant
l'absence de deux diffuseurs de l'aider
dans la suite c'était françois bozizé
actuellement à assurer l'intérim de la
présidence est relativement avec
françois bozizé qui a apporté son
soutien à la rébellion il a appelé les
centrafricains ne pas aller voter
massivement
vous soutenez cette démarche écoutez moi
j'ai pas impliqué donc moi
politico-militaire donc là je ne rejette
pas le collant de la sueur de graver à
jamais champion de discuter des
questions d'échelle
alors les groupes armés qui remettent en
cause l'accord de khartoum l'accord de
paix de khartoum signant en 2019
il s'agit d'une coalition de groupes
armés autrefois et demi est ce que
comment cette coalition s'est formée qui
la soutient exactement
en tout cas je suis un démocrate le
combat que je mène s'assurer dans un
stade et le public a donc je ne peux pas
répondre à la place des couples et donc
vous ne souhaitez pas répondre à la
place des groupes armés mais s'agissant
du cas de françois bozizé qui soutient
la rébellion quelle est votre position
par rapport à cela et écoutez moi je
vous dis que l'on sait rebondir et
président fondateur d'un parti politique
c'est fait le knk donc c'est dans ce
cadre là que nous sommes ensemble des
relations d asa et les autres activités
qui devaient traîner par le président
françois bozizé je ne peux pas en être
comptable très bien comment vous voyez
la suite de la la suite dans votre pays
en république centrafricaine après
justement la proclamation des résultats
est ce qu'il y aura un dialogue
politique
ce que vous y êtes favorable politique
il fallait le faire avant
et pour ça que nous allons demander un
report des élections non pas pour
aboutir à une transition et c'est moi
qui te permettent de centrafricains se
retrouver dans une concertation
nationale
voilà pour cet entretien avec nicolas
tchangaï donc qui est l'ancien président
du conseil national de transition de
2003 à 2005 ancien premier ministre de
la transition de 2013 à 2014